[Musique]
combien d'espèces de cactus pousse à
l'état sauvage au canada il existe au
pays
quatre espèces de cactus indigènes celle
qui pousse le plus au nord l eau
poussière fragilisent ou la raquette
fragile c'est aussi la plus répandue au
canada
on la trouve de la vallée de l'okanagan
jusqu'à fort de saint john en
colombie-britannique mais aussi dans les
prairies et jusque dans l'est de
l'ontario deux espèces elle dit jeunes
pousses au sud des prairies la mamie
leur vivipare et la raquette à plusieurs
aiguilles à la floraison en juin elles
sont faciles à identifier
elle porte de larges fleurs roses et
jaunes de 4 à 8 cm de diamètre leur
présence est un indice d'une terre
pauvre mais elles sont précieuses et
chiens de prairies et les antilopes
d'amérique sans nourrissent en période
de sécheresse ou en hiver quand la
nourriture est moins abondante la 4e et
la plus rare des espèces canadienne de
cactus
elle oppose de l'est extrêmement
résistante au froid
elle peut tolérer des températures
allant jusqu'à moins 25 degrés celsius
elle est considérée espèce en voie de
disparition et se limite à deux
populations au parc national de la
pointe pelée dans le sud de l'ontario
en plus de la perte d'habitat elle est
aussi victime de la cueillette illégal
à de rares exceptions près la très
grande majorité des 1600 espèce de
cactus du monde sont originaires d
amérique
mais au fait pourquoi les cactus ont-ils
des épines les épis leçons des tissus
morts
un peu comme des ongles elles
fournissent ombrage et protection contre
les mammifères gourmands elle permet
aussi à la plante de récolter la rose et
dont elle s'abreuve